no one remembers almost any of the names
of the Roman War Machine everybody still
remembers Jesus name
we Mark time by the way we we Mark time
human civilizations Mark time by the
birth and death of Christ all right the
most the the most attended worship event
in the of the year in human civilization
for going on a second Epoch is the is
the is the marking of the resurrection
of Christ followed only by the marking
of the birth of Christ so I would argue
his legacy is very intact when it's
those of people like me who believe that
he is God that he was resurrected and
the CH the testimonies that we have of
the changes that have gone on in our
lives and then we have gone on and
helped other people and do things that
are beyond our normal capability so we
don't give ourselves over to the
nihilism that Tim talks about I would
argue his legacy is intact all the
people that put him to death they're all
in the ground all right nobody cares
about any of them